hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about
how to learn to code as a beginner
really just the best way
to start your coding journey to start
learning how to code
in 2021 so let's get to it so if you are
looking to learn how to code odds are
you are looking to get
hired or paid for your work at some
point in time
so number one see what careers you can
get
with a programming language search types
of software engineers types of software
developers
and you'll see a list of front-end
developers back-end developers
game development etc and see what
languages
are needed to be employed as such
and so if you know you want to be a
front-end developer
back-end game dev or you do some reading
and you see that okay yeah i would
really like a career in
x y and z then this puts you in a great
spot in knowing
what to learn to code because each
career path tends to have their list
of languages that you either must know
or is highly recommended you know or as
long as you know this
your odds are you'll have a chance of
getting a job in
x and x fee this is also great for
knowing that you are learning to code
for a specific end goal in mind this is
what's going to put you
push you through those hard times rather
than oh i'm bored let me learn how to
code today and then
you never pick it up ever again so
having that end goal in mind
also helps with that learning process
but yes
try to see if there's a career path that
you really see stand out for you you
think would be a great
match in terms of personality wise and
just interesting to do
and go from there and actually my next
video is going to be
on how to pick that first coding
language to learn so make sure you
subscribe
so you don't miss that if you don't know
what career path you want to be on that
is totally okay
i didn't know a career path i wanted to
be on until i had found the languages i
liked and tailored the career path based
on the language so that's totally okay
what you can do instead is see what for
example
the easiest languages to learn are this
is the first thing i did
when learning how to code and i stumbled
upon
python python is known as one of the
easiest languages
to learn especially for beginners ruby
and javascript are also
great easy starter languages i started
with python and then i ended up
abandoning it because it just didn't
speak to my soul
and that's okay you're going to
encounter things like that
but those are different approaches to
finding your first coding language
again that'll be my next video but once
you find your coding language that you
are going to learn you're going to stick
to
you're next going to want to find the
resources to aid in your
learning some of the top resources
include free code camp
codecademy udemy and edx
i used all of these when first learning
how to code and so let me give you a
quick run through
of all of these different resources one
free code camp
free code camp is amazing i think they
do
great work over there especially with
beginner programmers
and so to me it's great as a beginner
with really figuring out the
foundational
things and really what's a p tag what's
an
image tag how do you add x y and z to an
html site and things like that
however i ended up
yearning for something more and so
that's when i
ended up going to codecademy and udemy
udemy provides
hours hours and hours and hours of tons
hundreds of different courses some of
which you can end up with a certificate
in that specific
course after you've completed it and so
it's great for beginners and it's also
great
when you are a person kind of needs a
teacher someone to follow along with
where udemy can kind of go wrong
is you can kind of get stuck in this
tutorial
just cycle of just doing tutorials after
tutorials and courses after courses
and meanwhile you don't really
know why you're doing what you're doing
you're just following along
now some courses they are great and you
won't
do this but there are many that you just
find yourself
following along to what the teacher or
instructor says
without really knowing why if you were
put in a room where you had to replicate
what you just did
you wouldn't even know where to start
and even why to start and it's
important to know the why however now
courses are like this some of them are
great i'll add links below for courses
that i've heard some people boast about
and so yeah just keep that in mind with
udemy make sure that when you're going
through them
you are understanding the why if you
don't understand the why
it's okay to break out and google
it ask okay what does an if statement do
what does x y and z do
and then go back to the to the tutorial
make sure
you're always understanding the meaning
behind some of these things moving on to
code
codecademy ended up being my main
resource for learning and i used their
web development course
which really goes into html css and
javascript
and i really liked codecademy up until
the part that it got to
javascript once i got to javascript it
felt
kind of like how udemy felt of this
following along of okay this is an if
statement but
why am i here why am i using this and so
that's kind of where i stepped off
from codecademy when i was just doing
things and understanding cost
concepts but not understanding how i
would use this at work how i would use
this
or when i would use it in building an
app not saying that
they weren't teaching the relevant
things it's that
i just didn't it didn't click
why i was learning it and for me i need
to know the why
i need to know the why and it's really
what makes a difference in my learning
and so right when we got to javascript i
kind of went off a bit
and went a different direction however
it is great for the beginner items it's
great for knowing the fundamentals for
knowing
just the foundation of concepts and so i
do still recommend and then lastly
there's edx
edx was great for understanding the
computer science
part of software engineering rather than
just the programming
and coding and so i used their i believe
was their harvard
computer science intro to computer
science course or something like that
i'm sure
everyone and their mom has heard of it
and so i'll leave a link to that
below as well and i really like this
because i was also a college student at
the time
when i was going through this and so i
really liked that lecture
feel of an actual instructor an actual
teacher
on the stage going over concepts and
material with students with freshmen
i really liked that feel and so i do
also recommend
that as well but overall don't be afraid
to try
all of these things out see which one
resonates best for you
and don't be afraid to switch around
some things like i said start with free
code camp it was great for beginner then
went on to udemy was it i don't remember
which came first udemy or codecademy but
yeah
went on to one of those did a little bit
of what i needed to do then moved on to
something else and so don't be afraid to
jump around and figure out what the best
course of action is for you after
finding a resource for learning
figure out your study plan it is
important
and maybe is this the planner in me i
define myself identify as a planner
it is important to have a plan because
it is that plan and that
goal that is going to get you through
the hard
days of wanting to quit wanting to just
be done with everything
it's the impending timeline that's going
to
drag you across the finish line and so
one way to do this is to work backwards
see
that okay i want to be a developer
within a year and so knowing that you
want to
have a job after 12 months of learning
then you can identify what things you
need to do now to get there
say okay so i want to be a web developer
in the next 12 months so it means i need
to do three hours of learning every day
every tuesday et cetera and build your
study plan
that way you can also go forward moving
where you really don't have a timeline
for yourself it happens when it happens
and really you're focused on learning
without
the impending deadline that you've set
for yourself that also works too and so
see
okay so i only have one hour of my day i
can allocate to
something that's not work related and so
i'm going to devote this one hour every
day to coding
so whichever way you choose make sure
you write something down have a study
plan and
stick to it seriously stick to it
because at some point you'll realize how
much material there is to learn
and you don't want to shoot yourself in
the foot by
not recognizing the gravity of what
you're trying to do here which is maybe
switch careers or
just get into your first career etc
that's a big thing and so make sure
you treat it like a big deal and have a
study plan next
build projects it's important to know
how to
think like a developer when you are
hired you are going to be expected to
think like a developer not just follow
along to instructions and the way you
think like a developer
is by building projects of your own now
following along when i say build
projects i don't mean following along
to some other udemy course that says
we'll build five projects
no put that away and think what kind of
project do you want to build what kind
of apps you want to build
so okay i want to create a financial
tracker
so have that goal in mind and start
building it out and so i say that not to
mean that
you have all the skills needed right now
to build it
you may not however you need to know how
to
learn you need to know where the gaps in
your knowledge are
and the best way to do that is by
building and so
you set on a plan to build a financial
app
and so now when after you build your
landing page or your static page with
html and css
you see okay i need to make this dynamic
and i need to make sure that each input
is recognized
so then you go to google and say how to
make sure user can
input new numbers to financial tracker
or something maybe not that
specific but but yes google things as
they come
and slowly build that way because trust
me
and you may not know this yet developers
use
google like they have stock in it we use
google
like it is running out of style like it
is
leaving at some point is about to become
extinct
you need to learn how to use google
effectively
like a developer because it's a way that
we problem solve
asking the right questions asking the
right resources
and seeing how best to use that
information
for our benefit for our apps for our
projects
you need to learn to do the same because
it will not end once you get the job
and so once you've developed the
fundamentals and once you've gotten a
bit more comfortable with the languages
that you've set on to learn
start building projects on your own not
with cold steel in the background like
no
on your own and it's going to be long
it's going to be painful
painful but it's really going to be what
teaches you the most because
tutorials do not teach you how to
problem problem-solve and now
after you've taken the time to learn to
grow to develop your own projects
start looking at job postings and no
this is not to
get the job right now i say this because
we want to see what jobs are looking for
in their candidates what things do you
see constantly pop
up in the job listing for back-end
developer
do you constantly see that they want you
to learn sql do you constantly see that
they want you
to actually have this type of skill when
using python et cetera so see
what job postings are saying about the
career path you want to be on
and now alter your learning to
account for these things to specifically
learn these things
that way when you are ready to go on the
job hunt you are not caught off guard or
you are not
constantly being passed off because
you don't have a specific skill that
they are looking for
that being said there are some jobs that
will
ask for the moon meanwhile are paying
you 15.50 an hour and everything
try to avoid those things try to instead
really focus on the patterns that you're
seeing
do five out of every eight jobs request
this specific thing
then add that to your list of things to
learn rather than
oh this one job out of the 20 i've
looked at
asked that i know postgres so avoid that
unless you would like to learn it that
is totally fine
but yes in terms of which things to
really make sure you
add to your learning list to your study
plan
go that direction and lastly don't be
afraid to rinse and repeat
don't be afraid to backtrack to
change languages to change courses to
figure out some type of other resource
to use for your learning
don't be afraid to rinse and repeat and
repeat and repeat
because odds are this for you is
uncharted territory and so
it's okay to see that okay i actually
did this wrong
let me go this direction and oh actually
this is wrong too let me go this
direction
don't be afraid of that instead
acknowledge that what you're doing
is growing and celebrate that be happy
that you're doing that
even if you end up after months of
learning deciding that
python isn't for you that is completely
okay and
you are you are completely okay changing
languages because you know what
even just knowing that little sliver of
python you just learned
that is going to help you at some point
in the future either on your learning
journey
seeing what things helped what things
didn't what resources helped what
resources didn't
or on the job when you see a posting
that says oh
knows basic python principles even
though it's for some web dev
posting and so note that there's no loss
in anything
everything is helping you grow and
develop and
you'll see how much that helped in the
end even
after you've changed direction please
don't forget to like and subscribe
if you enjoyed this and if you did don't
forget the next video
is going to be specifically on how to
choose a coding
language where i go much more into depth
onto the different
coding languages for different career
paths etc so
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you all later
bye